so what should i play let's actually
play another job of london
because
i sort of hinted it okay so
this this again gives us the choice
right we can go for a french
which my guess is chanzinio probably
plays because of how quickly
he played e6 but we can also preserve
the integrity here of
of the jabba london bishop or let's
actually go into a french i don't mind
[Music]
french is a very good conceptual opening
to illustrate
you know sort of key concepts and so
we've transposed into a french
and already a small but significant
mistake by transgenia what
is the issue with this move thank you
zuja for the gift to
nk j
um 327 it's a free juicer yes so our
knight on c3
it well it blocks the bishop number one
but number two it it
blocks the queen's defense of the pawn
it's very important to avoid that in the
french
and now we just take the free pawn so we
are now upon up
so knight f6 is is a sensible move
developing the knight
and here once again we have the choice
of moving the knight away or taking on
f6 since we're already up a pawn
there is no need to reinvent the wheel
we can just simplify the position
slightly and continue
the development of our king side so
knight takes f6 and then knight f3 is
going to be our next move regardless
and then we're just going to be up a
central pawn okay queen takes f6 doesn't
substantively change what we do but um
okay so once again we we have these two
bishops to develop we have the king
where should we plant our rf1 bishop
this is not a trivial question there are
several answers to this that are viable
what do people feel like this morning
i feel you know
i feel like uh blood so
really the the two squares that you guys
should be eyeing
are d3 and c4 now the reason that
and i know a lot of people are and let
me indicate the correct squares with the
red and then the incorrect squares with
the other colors
so the problem with bishop b5 who can
explain to me as we're sitting here
thinking what is the issue with bishop
b5 because the case that seems to be
made for bishop b5 is well
i'm pinning the knight i mean pins are
good right
but black just goes c6 right
try not to overestimate pins pins in
general are one of the most powerful
tactical concepts but they are also one
of the most
often overestimated things right because
pins can be
oftentimes gotten rid of you just lose
the tempo right and c6 is a healthy move
for black
because that pawn is going to control a
central square
so for that reason let's deploy our
bishop to d3
why would c why is c6 bad c6 is good for
black
and also black doesn't have to play c6
black could have just castled there and
our bishop would be sort of stuck
doing nothing on b5 okay so now what do
you guys say do we castle first or do we
maybe go bishop g5 which of the two
moves seems to be more circumspect
bishop b2 is just a little bit more
passive right i think you would agree
with me
the bishop here is just a little bit
more you know it's doing a little bit
more castle of course we don't want to
allow
a wayward check on e8 and we have a
fantastic setup here i know a lot of
people
probably are thinking greek gifts but
that's out of the window of the queen on
f6
yep there we go gigahertz on the same
page okay so how do we
and a lot of people really struggle
positions like these we're up a pawn we
have a great position
um now here's the first thing that i
want to make clear
you see this bishop on c1 we don't have
to
uh bring this bishop out this bishop is
already doing quite a bit quite quite a
bit more than perhaps people think
uh it's just it's fine on c1 for now
now there's a very typical plan in these
positions that you get taught
which involves building a battery uh and
building a battery with the queen in
front of the bishop in order to threaten
checkmate rookie one would be a good
general improvement but i want to
showcase
this idea so we start with the move c3
now this is good as a standalone move
because it
creates a little pawn chain and it it
supports even further
our main asset on d4 what is going to be
the next two moves
sorry what are going to be the next two
moves
bishop c2 followed by queen d3 you see
this so many times in various types of
positions
now you might wonder well why not play
queen c2 and save some time well
chess is you know the symmetry doesn't
work that way if you put the queen
before the bishop that battery is a lot
less effective in most cases
than putting the queen in front of the
bishop because then
the queen is able to lead and threaten
checkmate bishop h7 is not a
serious threat okay so c5 is a good move
but because our pawn is so well
protected we don't need to actually
react to that we can go bishop c2
right we don't we don't need to go d5 we
don't need to take we can just continue
with our plan
and let's see how black responds to this
and i will reward myself okay so c4 the
intention of this move is perfectly
clear
our opponent is trying to preclude the
move queen d3
and we think about and immediately ask
ourselves what the drawback is of this
move this leaves the pawn
sticking out like a sore thumb in the
textbook prescribed method
of of dealing with such a pawn
is to undermine it with the move b3 very
typical
and i love the amount of people
suggesting it excellent so if c takes b3
then we get rid of it we open up the a
file
if black goes b5 which i'm sort of
anticipating then we will talk about
that
i'm drinking hot tea okay so b5 now i
know
for a fact that a lot of you might be
thinking of a4
but i would push back on that just a
little bit folks and say that i want the
bishop to remain on c2 let's try to find
a different way
of attacking this pawn train perhaps
something less creative but more
effective because the problem with a4
it's not a bad move but after c takes b3
we get distracted our bishop has to move
out to b3
i want this bishop here so instead what
you guys might notice is this pawn
becomes quite weak now let's first take
on c4
in order to soften up that c4 pawn to
make sure it's not protected by anything
else
and then we go knight out back to d2 we
use our knight
to attack that one another idea would be
queen to e2
actually queen to e2 now that you guys
are suggesting it is a very smart idea
why why is queen e2 so good
and knight t2 has a similarly good
secondary idea
double up yeah queen e4
two ideas with one move
there we go battery checkmate threat how
does black defend against it well black
needs to make some sort of concession
now we're not attacking the rook here
that would be nice but we're not because
the knight defends it
excellent thinking guys bishop f5 we can
take that bishop remember we have an
x-ray defense on that square
so black has to make a very unpleasant
choice between g6
which would tremendously weaken the
king's side and queen g6 which would of
course
uh that oh we have a very five head move
after queen g6
and we'll get to it if he plays q6
otherwise he must allow the queen to get
to h7 which is devastating
so black is in a bit of a lose-lose
scenario that is how effective this
battery can be guys
queen g6 start thinking about what we
can do yes
so the obvious obvious is to take
on g6 twice and say that we are up two
puns in the end game great
but let me guide you through what i
notice here what do i see and you guys
already see what i see
i see this bishop and i see the screen
and i say x-ray
if this queen were gone this bishop
would be making contact with white
screen the ideal
uh move would be moving this queen away
with check
but barring that we would want to move
the screen away with a desperado
sacrifice if we're already moving the
queen away
we might as well take a bunch of black's
pieces with it right
boom goes the dynamite guys queen takes
a8 exposing the attack on blacks i mean
this one's in exchange
it doesn't win the rook doesn't win the
rook when's the exchange
because black can in fact take our
bishop
knight takes 8 is also possible then
we'll get into an end game
okay what do we do now because now the
queen is hanging
is our queen trapped
no it's not and it's not trapped for
several reasons we might as well gorge
on another pawn
queen c6 would have also been actually
queen c6 might have been a slightly more
accurate move
because this allows black's knight to
get very active queen c6 would have been
quite a bit more accurate
um although maybe the knight if oh no no
that attacks the bishop so
this is a bit a bit greedy that's okay
all right so this is a mistake
unfortunately slightly
um i think under calculated
because he saw that the rook is hanging
but if we calculate one step further we
see what
white has two ways to win
so first the first way to win is to take
on b6
and see that after he takes the rook we
take his bishop and we're up a piece
but if you wanted to be super clinical
about this and you guys are
i mean this awesome bishop d2 bishop d2
attacks the queen
we are then attacking simultaneously two
pieces we're attacking the queen
and we're attacking the knight the queen
must move to b2
after queen bishop d2 to protect the
knight and after that if we calculate
one step further
what is white's move in that position
it is a rook to be one skewering the
queen against the knight a very simple
line
but an instructive one loose pieces drop
off that rule
applies in so many different types of
positions and this will leave us
up a full rook the game is over
well there's no reason to put the f rook
because if we put the f rook on v1 then
this other rook on a1 is going to be
kind of stranded
uh let's leave the f-rook for any sort
of emergency defensive purpose
if queen d3 then we can straight away
take his night
okay let's take i'm not
i'm not like horribly sleepy but
definitely feel the fatigue but
i will be able to sleep a lot tonight
okay so bishop
bishop uh moves away to a3 what do we do
now
how how should we untangle our pieces
i know i did
yeah so bishop so like obviously if you
remember the two methods of converting
an advantage material advantage we have
trades and we have attack
it doesn't seem prudent to mount an
attack against black's king
but if we if we look specifically for
trades we notice that there's this
bishop in this rook on the same diagonal
we have the move bishop before forcing a
bishop trade good job
yeah you guys are i have to say very
sharp
i'm not missing that
yeah queen b1 would be possible but
perhaps a little bit passive
i live in beautiful city
okay so what do we do now in the same
spirit
yeah so 95 but counter argument doesn't
that blend to the pawn who can
who can um counter my counter argument
doesn't that blunder upon
well 95 doesn't want to take his pawn
nope i want somebody to give me a
conceptual point here
so let me try to i guess i'm i'm
ambiguous here the
the point is guys and i've i've made
this point many times
when you are up a rook it is fine to
give up a pawn
for the sake of doing something very
important i would say trading off the
last pair of minor pieces leaving us
with
just two rooks against one rook and
queens
is a worthwhile thing to give up a pawn
over i don't give a
rat's ass about this pawn on d4 and i
hope you don't either
because we're gonna win it's not about
it restoring material balance people get
obsessed with this
and um i also don't want people to come
around and start sacrificing stuff and
be oh
daniel you know i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
gonna sacrifice eight pawns
like that's not what i'm saying you have
to exercise your judgment as to
you know don't worry i won't say this
during the title commentary let's go
after this one as to like whether pawns
matter
in a certain position but in many
positions where you're up a ton of
messier i see people becoming obsessed
with keeping every last you know inch of
their kingdom
okay here we're going to bury destroy
black's kingdom good game
okay why would i take on f8 guys what is
the
purpose of that see that would exactly
fall into the category of unnecessary
unnecessary simplification unnecessary
simplification he's not going to
checkmate me with this rook
i i understand what you guys are doing
like if there was maybe like just the
queen and the rook against the rook i
would do it
but i want people to be careful in
regards to these kinds of
simplificational ideas simplifying ideas
okay um let's focus in on the game so
this transposes into the french now
here's
here's a piece of advice if you
are stuck in an opening if you've been
move ordered into an opening that you
don't play
if you've been move ordered into an
opening that you don't play
focus on what i would call the pressure
points like what
make sure you're not blundering anything
first and foremost
and uh it's less important to focus on
the accuracy so here for example d take
c4 would be a good option
you know focus on trading everything off
reducing the tension and then
developing healthy in healthy fashion
you're not going to get crushed if you
do that
knight d7 gets off on the wrong foot
takes takes takes and now
we're up upon so it takes
knight f3 with two his own uh bishop d6
bishop d3 i've had check
i've been to the czech republic yeah
yeah castles castles but chess is my
drug of choice
always and forever and openly and
proudly addicted
okay so this is
the position in which we we played c3
i've never had australian beer c3 bishop
c223 so let me show you guys
some similar positions on in top level
games
where this has happened let me do a
quick quick search
we see here this game guys navarra
against coleopolis
novara 2700 plus gm super nice guy
and uh let's practice the initiative
first of all in this position and
this is not yet a application of the
concept i'm
referring to what do you think why i did
hear a very nice move
to enhance the initiative
yeah i mean some people don't like tia i
definitely know people who don't
you should try loose leaf tea all right
so knight d5
is is very simple
and um this forces the queen back so
here in ivara
this is ceylon t so here navarro
basically spots a beautiful idea
now this bishop on c2 and i've already
many times talked about kinetic versus
potential energy you guys remember that
a lot of you would look at this bishop i
would look at this bishop and say this
is a terrible bishop
navarro looks at this and this says this
is the game-winning bishop all that i
have to do is get this measly pawn out
of e5
because he already sees that this
battery could be absolutely devastating
and so he goes f4
and black is pinned and tied up all over
the place there's nothing that black can
do
other than to meekly take boom goes the
dynamite
g5 black tries to counter-attack the
bishop and here white is already up a
piece
but navarro doesn't care just because
queen d3 and here we go
if g takes h4 this is not checkmate guys
the knight is
there but you can play knight takes f6
and then queen h7 may
so black plays rookie 8 and navarre
plays rook takes up for another very
nice move in black resigns
black resigns because the knight is
going to be taken by one of white's
pieces and if it itself moves then this
is an elementary mate
so this emphasizes the concept of
kinetic energy
and also the notion of this battery c2
d3 being incredibly strong
all right not nothing extraordinary but
i hope this puts things into
some sort of perspective for you guys um
and let's go back to the speed on game
all right
so that's why this is so effective c3
bishop c2
by the way if he had taken cd what is a
what is a five head move here
what is a what is a particularly five
head move here
avoiding autopilot
yeah queen d3 you can go here anyway
that's the effectiveness when you
threaten checkmate you don't give a
about anything else so once again this
would be fine
now b3 now you guys see in context why
we didn't
go a4 because then we would have to move
our bishop away
and this is not bad but like our bishop
is nowhere near c2 it would have to
spend another tempo going there
black could do something like this try
to trade the bishops off
so i decided okay we're gonna take here
and we're gonna go queen e2 now knight
d2
was my original intention and
what is the secondary purpose of knight
t2 where is this knight going what is it
doing
is this just an awkward move that blocks
the bishop well obviously it's not
bingo 94. and
uh we've done a couple of things we can
take this very nice bishop or we can
bring our queen out to h5 and maybe to
f5 constructing the battery
that would be one option so that's what
i wanted to do initially but i liked
an idea that people suggested because
this does sort of kill two birds with
one stone
now let me show you guys something
really cool
and a lot of people wonder well if you
were black here you know what would you
do how do gm's defend against stuff
let me walk you through 8 300 subs guys
amazing thank you so much everybody
if i was black what would i do here i
would start by noticing one
i would start by asking myself the sam
shanklin question
i would start by asking myself the sam
shanklin question is
queen takes c4 actually a threat so
let's make a random move
let's consider this for a second is this
actually a threat think about it
it is actually not and this is the
amazing part no why
because we look at this boom
bishop a6 pins the green to the rope
wait a second daniel what the hell are
you doing
well this is what i'm doing bishop h2
wins the queen so bishop a6 would win
the exchange
and so all you have to do is defend
against queen e4
and that is not as hard as it seems you
could play bishop b7 bishop b7
is i think black's best move and the
computer confirms it it's the only move
to retain a playable position now white
can go 92 here but now you can attack
the queen that's why i wouldn't go
queenie 2.
finding this is extremely hard it's
possible though if you ask yourself the
sam shanklin question
but it's it's hard to just do straight
off the bat because people assume
immediately that this pawn needs to be
protected that's why he played knight p6
this is the power of not making these
false assumptions
it's crucial do not let your brain
tell you what's what before you have
examined it from a concrete perspective
that's my advice rookie blunders the
rook
remember you haven't moved your bishop
so the rook is simply undefended
does that make sense now again
when i say these things you don't want
to
bring it to an obsessive level where
like every single threat
you well what if it's not really a
threat you have to exercise your dread
some threats you can immediately tell
like checkmate threats are
are checkmate threats you have to defend
against them but um
by applying this in certain positions
you can really enrich your tactical
vision
so if g6 then we can of course play
bishop takes h6
and a bishop f5 we can drop the queen to
e2 and we can protect the c2 bishop
simultaneously
well louis work loom just to recap if
queen takes a6 then you need to notice
this
and louis i want you to tell me lewis
work loom
what is black's move here help us out
here just to make sure you're paying
attention to the answer
i get satisfaction from seeing people
who have their
questions resolved but let's let lewis
work loom yeah bingo
beauty queen takes a6 wins the queen you
see no no no need to apologize
i'm not trying to be sarcastic here i'm
truly trying to make you
help you get better queen takes a8
and this idea i explained fully right uh
desperado sacrifice if he takes then we
take his queen
and um he plays sorry wrong
instance of the game sorry about that
okay so he plays queen c2 and a7 now
here the only
the only other chance would be to go
knight d5 this would actually create a
lot of
pressure on the c3 pawn and we would
probably go
i don't know that's why i would have
gone nice queen c6 maybe bishop d2 and
you know trade on c3 go rook c1 slowly
win this position
of course uh white is white is winning
here we're
up a lot of material and
after queen takes e3 we we play bishop
d2 we can also take here as i explained
essentially we have two pieces for a
rook and we have an extra piece here at
the end of it
and uh here here if queen b2 we go rook
b1 and we win
skewer the knight and win the knight and
um
queen d3 we take and we're up a rock
bishop b4 95
we don't care about the pawn we care
about the bishop and he gives
us the queen and makes the job easier is
bishop h6 any good
instead of exchanging bishops um
no because you just don't
quite have enough there and i can go
back to g6 and
you know it's it's possible but why why
risk it it's the sort of thing where
you're up a rook and
trading pieces would be easier here if
that makes sense
when queen is on c3 why not take a
knight on b6 and if queen takes a1 oh
you want to propose an alternate idea
yes so you want to trap the queen
unfortunately if you look a little bit
carefully
you'll notice that the queen can
evacuate itself here and then and then
here
so not quite able to do that
[Music]